ich habe ehrlich gesagt gar keinen bock
erste stunde
ja darum geht es in dieser serie was
was ist jetzt sein wird fragt ein
mädchen bildeten sorge tragen können
jetzt sagt das mädchen
nein sagt der junge mann trägt ein bh
also
mit abstand
du willst du nicht ihr gehört haben
allerdings sehe ich gerade es geht hier
sogar noch weiter
kommt er einfach nach hause bereitet ein
ritter an einer lösung hülle vorbei auch
mögliche wieder dosenfutter dosenfutter
weil weil ritter mit mit schild und
schwert und metall und klose haben wir
gelacht wie nennt man ein ritter ohne
helm
wilhelm ich solange ich bei so einer
scheiße wilhelm evoluce entschlossen
mich zum lachen bringen kann
ja
hat sie das kissen im ich es auch
mitten im schlaf wie nennt man es luca
ein salto macht bottle flip
model flippen
h
so schlecht ach ja doch gerade ich habe
ja nicht schon zehn millionen mal in die
kommentare geschrieben
ein griff zum arzt will könig zum arzt
gehen
das rezept hat doktor ich hab's
schrecklichen haus fall sagte doktor
sich überweisen sie in die reha klinik
die reha klinik
mit
das hat
reha klinik doch dass das haben wir
gesagt alle kinder angeln high noon
nicht schröder der köder
auch der war
ja ganz beschissen sagte eine 23
treffen sich zwei fische
zudem haben uns wirklich schon im bauch
meiner mutter erzählt aber das video
geht hier noch ein bisschen
hier schaut mal was ich auch gerade alle
aber das hier ist erst meine christmas
weiter meine damen und herren wir haben
uns gedacht hey komm weihnachtszeit ihm
das ding ist in und imitiert und es gibt
doch so ein bisschen mehr als 100 stück
davon den 60 euch runter auf 29 eur 99
wollte ich euch nur kurz sagen dass wir
diesen limitierten smiley tourismus
weiter heruntergesetzt auf 25 eur 99 und
wenn ihr euch den bestellen möchte dann
seid lieber schnell weil davon gibt es
wirklich nicht mehr ganz soviele und
wenn der noch vor weihnachten ankommen
soll dann am besten innerhalb der
nächsten 45 tage bestellen luca minister
punkte und jetzt kommt der nächste witz
privater hand kommen schreibt so schnell
antwortet fritz ich muss schnell
schreiben vergleicht diese witze andere
eindrücke berichtete gefinkelt gebrochen
rechtzeitigen ausgebrochen 8 mrz
das war durch die luft alle kinder
stehen und der peter geht noch um meter
an der stelle und meine eltern haben mir
verboten einen facebook account
anzulegen
deshalb mache ich jetzt facebook möchten
wir von haus zu haus erzählt was ich
gerade gegessen habe was ich gerade
getan hat und was er tun möchte noch
zwei tagen hat und die von zwei
polizisten und einen psychiater
sollte da
kann
ein witz sein
oder kommt der her noch das allerbeste
abonniert auf youtube
erstmals ende der mit dem geschützten
witz west ein
und dann sagt er auch noch auf youtube
komm ducati auf wir haben noch ein paar
witze und rollt den werken eine lawine
mit heimweh
wow
ja humor preisverdächtig verfahren kommt
ein fahrradfahrer vorbei
bei einem vampir er saugt ihn aus von
kommt noch ein paar sachen aus und sagt
der polizist was haben sie denn
getrunken
zwei radler
am liebsten etwas böses sagen aber die
person hat sich 4 luca pizzen gekauft es
war echt richtig lustig lukas chancen
ja das ist mein zuhause ich hatte
meine mutter hat mir gedroht wenn
dieses geschenk macht zu nutzt die sun
habe jetzt eine kerze gekommen
diese witze
das ist wie wenn man sonnen
darunter fällt also vom niveau
allerdings dann nicht dass man niemandem
tal ist sondern dass man in den erdkern
rein so da sind wir mittlerweile vom
niveau wie ein koch der seine tage hat
red bull
mein gott wie kommt man denn auch so was
wie man ein fan ohne hennen han solo
eigentlich
könnte ich dieses gewicht was ich mache
also dass hier
könnte ich nur einmal aufnehmen und in
jeder lukas länder nach jedem witz
reinschreiben takt für takt wusste was
ist der unterschied zwischen niemanden
der zum zehnten stock springt mit einem
davon ersten stock spring erster stock
klatsch sind dass der heirat hat
will ich nichts gegen sagen der war
zumindest noch ansatzweise kreativ
allerdings hat sie hier noch einen
zweiten sitz mit dabei ist dass sie die
sonst gute tipps und werbespots
also nach dieser folge werde ich mir den
kopf einschlagen 17 europas ist die
sahne stube sagt opa zu fritzls prinzip
kann zu kurz angeschlagen gehen und
zigaretten kauft sagt 14 okay geht fritz
in dem tisch stand sogar eine stange
zigarette sei der verkäufer eines noch
zu jung zu hause opa ich benutze um
zigaretten zu kaufen sagt fritz und sagt
du bist 38 jahre alt hat ein kind der
frau liegt im gebrochenen bein im
krankenhaus in deinen ausweisungen
kollege fallen geht das mit ihr sagt
hallo ich bin frist sind ich bin ein
jahre alt hat 38 kinder meine frau ist
mir nie gefallen und meinen ausweis es
mit liegt nun mit einem gebrochenen bein
im krankenhaus
was ein point frag nicht darf ich ein
stückchen von deinen dass ich mit der
antwort ja du darfst die mitte weil er
mit der dik dritte aber das wird sich
dein auge zum weinen ich geh jetzt weg
sagt das bein zum augen
das will ich sehen
nö
natürlich wollte ich kegeln gehen zu
wollen
macht ein ofen wenn er böse er geht auf
ach das läuft noch wie viel haben wir
dann noch
okay ein ein witz noch dass es keinen
ganzen welt ein rudel gucken
wow wirklich einfach einfach nur wow
da fragt man sich wirklich nicht mehr
warum das hier die beschützende serie
auf youtube ist anders stelle sich das
heutige media jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine damen und herren wenn euch
diese dritte episode von lukas leute
gefallen hat dann lasst mal einen fetten
leichter schaffen wir 50.000 like werk
halt diese serie heftig bei euch ankommt
deswegen kriegt die lukas glaube ich sie
hin beide ebenfalls einen lustigen witz
habt dann apostel gern ein video auf
instagram unter dem hashtag lokale wo
ihr euch filmt oder irgendetwas anderes
filmt und diesem bis einfach vorliest
und mit etwas glück kommt die in die
nächste episode
abonniert main kanal drückt auf die
glocke wenn ihr schon ein moment sei
dann bekommt den benachrichtigungen den
hier wie gesagt der wird runtergesetzt
den gibt es im shop